Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed, Noble and Fully Self-Enlightened One.
The
meditation that we do this vipassana puts us into a sort of peculiar position with ourselves because having found this position within ourselves we sort of abstract from everything that we would normally call ourselves everything becomes an object something to observe
somehow we have to re-enter that psycho-physical organism and sort of wander about the world.
Sometimes we mistake that meditation in day life thinking that we have to be self-aware to try and keep this sort of distance within ourselves.
Well, that of course creates quite a split.
And although self-awareness does arise at times, even if it arises in not such a skillful way, such as when we're embarrassed,
You become very self-aware.
But the fact that it arises sometimes is not a problem.
But if we make that, if we think that that's the way we ought to be, then it does become a problem because there's a split.
There's me trying to watch myself trying to do something.
It's just, you can't do it if you haven't got bills anyway.
Try reading, watching yourself read.
You can't do it.
So we have to re-engage
Now what we come to recognize within ourselves is that a lot of the things that we do are coming from wrong attitudes.
So, you know, in the classic teaching it's all to do with greed, with acquisitiveness, all to do with aversion and fear, anxiety, both, you know, that sort of aversion of pushing away and the aversion of running away.
So, knowing that, it's important before we begin an action to actually be quite clear about our attitude.
And in the Eightfold Path, remember, this right understanding is first, is what we get through the meditation.
And it drops into a right attitude, into a heart state.
So that attitude, remember, is not an emotional state, it's where you put your wills.
why are you doing what you're doing so being very clear about that when you enter into the action then we're producing good conditionings within ourselves
just on a very simple level, if you say that you'll help somebody, you see, you might be in a habit of just saying yes.
You know, will you do this?
Yes.
And then after you've said it, you say to yourself, what did I say that for?
I don't want to do that.
And you get quite negative about it.
And you do it, but there's a grudge there.
So what was meant to be a very beautiful thing, a very happy thing to do, turns into something quite
painful now if you have stopped you see it and then actually made that as a point of reflection and then said yes i'll help then that comes from a right attitude and then you get the gift of happiness from it
So that ability to make the right intention, in order to do that, we've got to get in the habit of stopping, of actually just a moment of reflection.
And that's one of the very skillful habits that we can get into.
So when you've finished an action, no matter what it is, and there's a stop,
and the next intention comes and you can see that intention if you don't stop then you're in that sort of rush mode so if you look at the Eightfold Path you see it begins with this right understanding we form an intention from it which is the right attitude and then that affects the way we speak
what we do, and our livelihood, how we're actually making a living.
Now the two main attitudes or the two main positions that we have to take is this sense of attention.
Sense of putting our attention where we want to put it.
And the other one is care.
That's where we put the heart.
So these two things, attention and care, are the sort of guiding modes that we need for everything we do.
So, to get that attention right, it's a case of putting ourselves into the action, a sort of full engagement in what we're doing.
Now, it's at those points that we see that sense of self-awareness disappears.
And if it comes with care as well, then the heart's behind it, and you find that that movement into a loss of self-awareness into what you're doing comes with ease.
Now it happens to us naturally when we're doing something we love to do.
I mean, if you're a gardener, for instance, you might finish something, and when you look back at the action, you can see that it's done beautifully, it's done well.
But there's been not a sense of time.
There's been no sense of time.
And during that no sense of time, there's been no sense of self.
So there's an absorption into the action.
Sometimes you do it when you're reading.
You do it easily when you're watching a film.
No sense of time.
You just wake up and it's two hours long, is it?
Those moments when they actually...
happen from the right understanding, with the right attitude, you see, when we go into that sort of experience, that's the enlightened mind.
And we're in that peculiar paradox, that when we're completely happy like that, we don't know it.
As soon as you know you're happy, you lost it.
Because you know, I am happy.
See, there's a split, there's a break between the happiness and you knowing that you're happy.
And then, of course, you know it's going to end anyway, because everything arrives and passes away.
Now, on the other side of the equation, that is that the negativity that we have
which is sort of stored up from past behaviour, from past wrong thinking.
So now, what we learn from our meditation is that you don't fight it, you don't try and get rid of it, you have to, as it were, accompany it.
So, take our work, I would say it's impossible to do a job without sometimes feeling bored about it.
So, where does that boredom come from, you see?
Why does boredom arise?
It's one of our big problems in this society because of the access to easy pleasure, easy entertainment, easy distraction.
So when the mind is always seeking some sort of excitement,
and you have to go back and do the same sort of work and say the same things day after day, and there isn't the excitement there, then what you get is this aversion, which is boredom.
So then the boredom says to you, look, what you need is variety.
Variety is the spice of life.
So then you go seeking this variety, but it becomes a sort of,
Obsession.
An addiction to try and constantly find the next buzz.
And the more you work at that, the more you find that you're more quickly bored by what you're doing.
Because you can't keep that high level of excitement all the time.
So when we find ourselves being bored about something, the answer to that is repetition.
You keep doing it.
You keep doing it knowing that the boredom is there and that it's coming from wrong understanding and you keep placing your attention on what you're doing.
And then we find, magically, that the interest rises again.
The commitment rises again.
So now to undermine all this business around
seeking excitement in life, is the quality of equanimity, calmness.
And you'll notice that we always begin the meditation with that calmness.
And it's really beginning to develop a taste for calmness, for the neutral, for a state of equanimity that begins to balance our lives, so that we're not always seeking this excitement, this distraction,
And in a sense, that's our default position.
If during daily life we can just, every so often, even if it's only for a few seconds, just fall back into that state of stopping, re-establish the calmness of the body, calmness of the mind, the stillness, silence of the mind, calmness of the heart, and then in that position,
He wants to retain that.
So as it were, open outwards.
So it's a receptive mode.
So we're not going out, we're receiving.
And that's your equanimity.
If that's your default position, you can see that anything which touches that equanimity is going to be interesting.
Because you're not walking into the next moment with some preconception, some expectations.
Some idea of attaining or getting or achieving.
So in that default mode where they're just very calm, very still, very equanimous, we can repeat to ourselves that at this moment of being, not trying to become something, we're not achieving anything, going anywhere, not trying to be anybody.
That's a relief, huh?
That's a real holiday.
And then, when the next thing to be done arises in the mind, the next thing to be done, wash the pots, make the intention, wash the pots.
And when you wash the pots, your attention is on what you're doing.
If you're speaking to somebody, your attention is on receiving what they're saying without trying to respond at the same time, which is what we normally do.
We get into a sort of fencing.
It's more important for them to understand what I mean rather than for me to understand what they mean.
It's not important.
So that receptive mode, and then there's a sort of change, there's sort of a click of...
respond so all these little everything that we're doing in the sitting meditation has some relevance into daily life it's sort of the basic attitude in which we approach every moment in our lives
And the effect is, you know, just a greater calmness, a bit more happiness around.
Not so many enemies.
So, just to sort of recap, we're not trying to be self-aware.
In fact, we're trying to go to a point where we're not self-aware.
The guiding principles are paying attention and to do it with care, to put the heart into it, to make sure the intention that we are empowering is skillful, wholesome, and that we create during the day these moments of stillness.
The more you create moments of stillness to establish that equanimity and move into the next moment, you'll see it has just the effect of calming our lives
Just that moment allows us to make the right decision, you see.
Don't get caught up in the old habits of greed, hatred, fear and delusion.
I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you be liberated in this very lifetime, sooner rather than